this morning we're investigating
concerns about the safety of LASIK eye
surgery already performed on an
estimated 20 million Americans LASIK has
been popular for more than 20 years as a
way to correct nearsightedness and
improve distance vision but some
patients say the surgery has ruined
their eyesight dr. tara Narula is here
with the possible risks and a push to
have government approval for lasik
overturned how does the procedure work
good morning Anthony so LASIK is laser
guided surgery advertises a way for
people to fix their vision and shed
glasses and contact lenses the quick
minimally invasive surgery uses a laser
to cut a flap to reshape the cornea at
the front of the eye while surveys show
high patient satisfaction those who have
had bad experiences report painful
life-changing complications and now an
expert who once backed LASIK is
campaigning to get it off the market
it's a devastation that I can't even
explain
Abraham Rutner says LASIK surgery
damaged his vision and nearly ruined his
life so what happened after the surgery
things would appear double around the
lights were like having Star Wars after
months of not being able to drive or do
his job the Brooklyn electrician finally
found help in Miami his corneas very
distorted as a result of his LASIK
surgery where optometrist Edward Bosch
neck fitted him with special contact
lenses Bosch neck estimates he's treated
thousands of patients with lasik
complications
Paula Cofer had surgery 19 years ago and
from Des Moines my vision was an
absolute train wreck and it still is
today she started a lasik complications
support group on Facebook and quickly
found she was not alone you really have
to understand you're risking your only
pair of eyes are you feeling since 1998
an estimated 20 million LASIK procedures
have been performed and according to an
FDA patient survey more than 95% of
patients were satisfied with their
vision after surgery still the FDA's
website is filled with stories of
serious complications
patients report relentless eye pain
dizziness detached retinas and tell the
agency LASIK ended my life and this
procedure needs to stop essentially we
ignored the data on vision distortions
that persisted for years
Morris Waxler is a retired FDA adviser
who voted to approve LASIK he now says
that vote was a mistake we examined the
documentation and I said while this is
not good
wax ler says his own analysis of
industry data shows complication rates
between 10 and 30% in 2011 he petitioned
the FDA to issue a voluntary recall of
LASIK three years later the agency
denied that request and now tells CBS
News it quote has not found any new
safety concerns associated with lasik
devices do you think that this should be
taken off the market absolutely there's
nothing wrong with a person's eyes who
goes to get LASIK they could go and get
the pair of glasses doctors who perform
LASIK surgery say risks can be minimized
with pre-surgical screening the most
important thing is knowing who to
operate on and who not to operate on and
there are people who really should not
have this procedure
Abraham Rutner now believes he was never
a good candidate and I was blaming
myself why in the world did I go into it
Ratner estimates his vision is now about
90 percent improved he tolerates the
discomfort of hard contact lenses but
wishes he had known more before he had
LASIK what would you tell someone who
came to you and said they were
considering having LASIK done think it
over and it's your eyes it's not
something that you could rectify later
doctors we spoke with stressed the
importance of pre-surgical screening to
make sure the patient is a good
candidate okay I'm officially terrified
good information for people to know
reason I got glasses on yeah thank you
very last night yeah I close up sir over
don't worry